an application programming interface or
api is a way for two computers to talk
to each other using an api is just like
using a website in your browser but
instead of clicking buttons and filling
out forms you write code to explicitly
request data from a server for example
we could visit the nasa website to look
at asteroids or we could use their rest
api to request the raw json data that is
shown on the screen now most apis in the
world are restful which means they
follow a set of rules or constraints
known as representational state transfer
which has been the de facto standard for
api development since the early 2000s a
restful api organizes data entities or
resources into a bunch of unique urls
well technically not urls but uris or
uniform resource identifiers that
differentiate different types of data
resources on a server a client can get
data about a resource by making a
request to that endpoint over http the
request message has a very specific
format most importantly the start line
contains the uri that you wish to access
which is preceded by an http verb or
request method which signal your intent
with the resource a get request means
you just want to read the data while
post means you want to create a new
resource patch is for updates delete is
for removing data along with a few other
methods beyond those below the start
line we have headers which contain
metadata about the request the accept
header can tell the server you want the
data in a specific format or the
authorization header can be used to tell
the server that you're actually allowed
to make that request then following the
headers we have the body which contains
a custom payload of data the server will
receive the request message then execute
some code usually to read from a
database that can then be formatted into
a response message the top of the
message contains a status code to tell
the client what happened to their
request codes at the 200 level mean that
things went well at the 400 level it
means something was wrong with your
request and at the 500 level it means
that the server failed after the status
code we then have the response headers
which contain information about the
server that's followed by the response
body which contains the data payload and
is usually formatted in json when
talking about apis now an important part
of this architecture is that it's
stateless which means that the two
parties don't need to store any
information about each other and every
request response cycle is independent
from all other communication and this
leads to well-behaved web applications
that are predictable and reliable this
has been restful apis in 100 seconds if
you enjoyed it leave a comment below
then next week i'll pick out the best
one to win this free t-shirt and now
it's time to go beyond 100 seconds to
build a restful api from scratch the
most popular framework for building
restful apis in node is express.js it's
been around forever and it's very
minimal and easy to learn if you know a
little bit of javascript over the next
few minutes we'll use express to build
our own restful api from scratch you'll
learn how to create different endpoints
for your api we'll also look at slightly
more advanced concepts like middleware
and tools in the cloud for deploying
your api like api gateways to get
started you'll want to open up vs code
to an empty directory you'll need to
have node.js installed and i'm using
version 12 for this video to start a new
node project let's run npm init y from
the command line
this will create a package json and give
us a context for installing packages
that we can use in node like express
let's go ahead and install express using
npm install you'll notice that adds
express to our dependencies in the
package.json file from there we'll need
a file to write our code in so let's
create an index.js file at the top of
that file we'll declare a variable for
app which represents the actual api that
we're building and its value is an
import of the express package which
itself is a function so we'll add
parentheses after it to initialize it
now at this point our api hasn't defined
any endpoints but let's go ahead and run
it anyway the way you fire up your api
on the server is by calling app.listen
that tells it to listen on a specific
port which we've defined as its own
separate variable as 8080. then as an
optional second argument to listen we
can fire a callback to let us know when
the api is ready and we'll just have it
console log the main url we can now run
the api by going to the terminal and
running node period to run that index.js
file and it should console.log it's live
on localhost 8080. if we paste the url
into the browser you can see we get a
message of cannot get that's because we
don't have any api endpoints set up yet
but express is still responding with an
error message in fact you can open up
the network tab in chrome if we look
closely we can see that our server
responded with a 404 status code meaning
that page was not found at this point we
know our api is working but debugging it
in the browser is usually not the best
option there are many different ways we
can access our api we could use curl
from the command line we could install a
vs code extension or we could use a rest
client like insomnia or postman i'm
going to be using insomnia throughout
the rest of this video because it
provides a really nice way to format
your requests and also view a history of
all your interactions from insomnia we
can create a new request then simply
paste in our url
we can easily change the http verb from
the drop down menu here click send and
then get the response in a nicely
formatted developer friendly way we can
even see the timeline here with our
request in yellow and the response in
green but now we need to get back to our
javascript and add an endpoint to the
api we can do that by changing an http
verb to the app instance if you type a
period after app you'll get intellisense
on a bunch of different methods that
live on this object and you'll notice
methods for git post patch etc which
represent different http verbs if we
want to add a get endpoint to the
t-shirt uri we can do that by passing
t-shirt as its first argument
that'll automatically set up our server
with that endpoint then it's our job to
handle a request to it which we do by
passing a callback function as the
second argument whenever a client or end
user requests that url it will fire this
callback function to handle the request
the function itself provides access to
two different objects the request object
and the response object the request is
the incoming data while the response is
the data we want to send back to the
client the most important thing it does
is allow us to send a response back to
the client that response can have a
status code like 200 for an ok response
then we can send a data payload along
with it if we pass a javascript object
as the argument then it will send that
data back as json by default let's go
ahead and save the file then restart the
server from the terminal from insomnia
we can then make a get request to
localhost 8080 t-shirt when we do that
we get a json object back as the
response body with a status code of 200.
that's pretty cool but now let's go back
to our code and add a second endpoint
this time a post endpoint followed by a
slash and a dynamic url parameter that
represents the id of that t-shirt there
might be millions of different t-shirts
on this api and a dynamic url allows us
to handle all of them from a single
function when dealing with a post
request it means that the user is trying
to create new data on the server or
create a new t-shirt in this case first
we need the id which we can get from the
url and its value is made available to
us on the request parameters object
second we also need a logo for the
t-shirt but the logo is contained in the
request body which if you remember from
earlier is a custom data payload
contained in the incoming request in
other words the request object in
express allows us to access information
from the request message like the url
parameters the body the headers etc and
now that we have that information we
could use it to save a new record to the
database or something along those lines
that's beyond the scope of this video
what we'll do for right now is check to
make sure that we have a logo in the
request body and if we don't then we'll
send an error response with a 418 status
code and an error message that we need a
logo
but assuming we do have a valid logo we
can just send a response with a t-shirt
that contains that logo and id now let's
go back to insomnia and we'll make a
post request to that t-shirt endpoint
followed by a unique id that can be
whatever you want then in the body
section we'll go ahead and add a request
body with a format of json and it's just
a json object that contains a logo with
a string value if we send that request
you'll notice we get a 500 error
response which means our api code is
broken so what's going on here it's
telling us we have a runtime error
because we can't destructure the
property logo from the request body the
reason for that is that express does not
parse json in the body by default not
everybody uses express to build a json
api so that's not the default behavior
what we need to do here is set up
middleware that tells express to parse
json before the actual data hits the
function that we're using here to handle
the request when you hear the term
middleware think of shared code that
runs before every endpoint callback that
you've defined very common middleware is
built into express itself we can
refactor our code here a little bit to
make a variable for express and then we
can call app.use to apply middleware in
this case the middleware we want to
apply is the express.json middleware now
every request that comes in will first
go through this express json middleware
which will convert the body to json
therefore making it available in our
post callback let's go ahead and save
restart our server and then go back to
insomnia and if we send the same exact
request you'll notice this time we get
back a successful response
in addition if we make the logo an empty
string and try to send the same request
we get a 418 response along with a
message that we need a logo
congratulations you just built a restful
api from scratch with node.js and
express but before we wrap up the video
there's one more thing you should
definitely know about when it comes to
restful apis and that is the open api
spec which provides a standard way to
describe an api in yaml it originally
came about in something called the
swagger framework and what it allows you
to do is describe your api in a way that
can be understood by both humans and
machines and if you're building a
serious api you get all kinds of awesome
benefits in the process your api will be
fully documented making it much easier
for the end user to work with and
because it follows a standard format you
can actually just automatically generate
all of your client-side or server-side
code what i'm using right now is a free
tool called swaggerhub and i can come up
here and hit the export button to
automatically generate a bunch of
boilerplate code now i'm usually not a
huge fan of code generators but there's
a more powerful reason to use open api
when you describe your api with the open
api spec you can then upload the
configuration to tools like api gateway
on aws or google cloud where it can be
secured monitored and connected to
backend infrastructure let me know if
you want to see a full tutorial on that
topic but i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there and if you want access
to even more advanced content consider
becoming a pro member at fireship io
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one